well our class takes a broad view of
philanthropy we talk about how you use
your time your talent and your treasure
to change the world on Noah you've been
of impacting philanthropy because you
advise people and entities and how they
use their time talent and treasure how
did you become engaged in this I suppose
it was quite a circuitous route really
and by starting this part of my career
at the Commonwealth Development
Corporation which was the United
Kingdom's development finance
institution there had been a very strong
focus on small and medium-sized
enterprise development and that by the
mid 90s had really sort of intercepted
with what we can now call the accession
of the sustainability debate the
sustainability discussion and came to be
labeled impact investing with the idea
already by the mid-90s was that by
boosting and supporting growth in the
SME sector or if SME its small and
medium-sized enterprise sector this was
a way of promoting not just economic
development but also private sector
development economic growth and
ultimately potentially controversial II
in some cases poverty alleviation